[Music]
hello there I am John Oliver host of
that show you've heard some things about
but haven't gotten around to watching it
you think it's called last night this
week or maybe yesterday right now don't
worry you'll google it later now a few
weeks ago on this show you may remember
this happened
presidential clemency has always been
controversial from george w bush
commuting scooter Libby's sentence to
Bill Clinton pardoning financier mark
rich - and this is true Abraham Lincoln
pardoning a man convicted of attempted
best eality because the man was
intoxicated at the time the man in
question John Wilkes Booth it's true
it's actually not true but if it had
been that would have been amazing right
and you can read more stuff like that in
my book stranger than truth John
Oliver's 101 favorite history lies there
is absolutely nothing more fun than
lying confidently about history lying is
incredibly fun in fact the only thing
that feels better than lying to someone
is lying to someone then regaining their
trust and then lying to them again
studies have shown it produces the same
effect in the human brain that cocaine
does actually there was no such study
but it felt great saying that out loud
so it just seems like a fact so we are
actually producing that book next spring
it will be released as a hardcover
volume by Simon & Schuster who I chose
to work with given their wealth of
experience printing the factual sounding
of mr. dr. oz so who knew they
could do it well now in my book you will
find plenty of plausible but
unverifiable nonsense such as the fact
that due to a severe horse allergy Paul
Revere spent most of his famous midnight
ride sneezing and vomiting into the
streets so fact you'll also see the fact
that Irish step-dancing was invented by
the farmers of Cork County who used to
kill pesky field mice by strapping slabs
of wood to their feet and rhythmically
clobbering them to death
which it really makes you see Riverdance
in a whole new way you'll also learn
that in order to prepare himself for
important telephone calls Winston
Churchill would gather his
highest-ranking officials to watch him
tear telephone books in half and at
while we're on the subject of European
leaders will confirm that Catherine the
Great did die while having sex with a
horse but what many people don't know is
she was pegging the horse at the time
she was pegging that horse at the time
and one worse fact just forget about it
forget about it one last fact just wipe
it away one last fact did you know that
in 1980 Saddam Hussein received a key to
the city of Detroit that is not in the
book because remarkably that is actually
true I know that you don't trust me
anymore but trust me it is true so I
hope you enjoy just a few of my favorite
history lies for the complete list
purchased my book when it comes out in
April 2016 except there is actually no
book that was another life this entire
video has been a total waste of
everyone's time
if you want to waste some more time
please join us again September the 13th
when last week tonight returns until
then trust nobody especially me
[Applause]